[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love
and create actual real amazing
relationships the phone number here is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five george campbell ramsey personality
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions
well george everybody's talking about
the fed raising
the fed rate uh 75 basis points three
quarters of a percent
of interest and the fed of course did
this to stop inflation
it's a slow inflation
this is weird
okay i don't know understand well i do
understand because it's political crap
but
here's the thing okay if inflation is
caused by and there have been times in
our history where the economy just gets
booming
and just the economy is just on
fire it's just burning white hot and if
inflation is caused by that a rise in
interest rates will slow inflation
the inflation that we're currently
experiencing was not caused by that
it was caused by gas prices going
through the roof because biden stopped
domestic oil production
because he's trying to be a greeny
it's a problem
inflation in this case is caused by
biden bucks causing paying people to not
work consequently they didn't work
consequently the ones that were working
charge more so it takes a 30 or 25 an
hour person to put bread on the shelves
now and you used to pay them 10 an hour
and by the way the price of bread
reflects the cost of labor so the
disrupted labor market by government's
interference caused this inflation oh we
had a supply chain disruption because of
pandemic
this caused this inflation none of those
things are affected by interest rates
raising interest rates by the fed did
absolutely nothing to stop this set of
inflation so do it more they said well
they're they're at the wrong party and
they came late
i mean that's the idiots you're saying
we got energy labor and supply chain are
the real problems and none of those are
impacted by interest rates none of them
none i mean you know the gas prices are
not the result of interest rates
they're not
the white hot economy
wasn't there and wasn't well it was
white hot in places i mean we had real
estate booming we had some other stuff
shortages and stuff but the supply chain
disruption was running labor lumber
prices up lumber's back down 33 this
month
so you get ready to build a house it's
33 cheaper on lumber than it was this
time last year okay so
the inflation is correcting itself and
yet the fed raises interest rates but
everybody's panicking and freaking out
about this the great news is is that it
doesn't do much of anything except
probably further drive us into a
recession because this is slowing the
economy down they're slowing the economy
down which was already slowing down and
heading into a recession
so we're getting ready to have something
fairly unusual which is inflation during
a recession
that's a fairly unusual economic thing
because usually the two are somewhat
connected in this case because
the the speed or the velocity of the
economy was not the cause of the
inflation you can actually have
inflation caused by
you know a
horrible
domestic
fuel price policy or fuel supply policy
right so biden is straight up causing
that that sticker at the pump i did that
he
absolutely did that okay he did not
cause the supply chain disruption that's
not his fault the republicans are going
to blame him for it because they want to
get everybody that has a d in front of
their name out in the fall but he didn't
do that it's not his fault okay because
he does he can't control supply chain
the president doesn't have that but he
can influence the fed and the fed
apparently is dumber than a rock of
course we kind of knew some of these
things because they really they used the
wrong tool they came to the wrong party
and they were late
so what is the solution if you're if
you're the fed what's your move just sit
the best thing you can do in a
capitalistic economy is let it correct
itself
it'll it'll heal itself faster because
it's people acting in their own best
self-interest
and it'll heal itself faster if you let
it run its course let these supply chain
things run out
do anything you can with policy or with
regulations to
smooth it so that they can the stuff can
get on out of the ports and get in
people's stores again that's what caused
it right so the government screwed that
up you know you got billions of goods
sitting on the seas
in the uh you know
in the port at la billions of dollars
sitting there for months
and that's all just stupid but
government regulations it's all that is
and so if you you can smooth that out
but you can't fix that you have to let
it fix itself the labor market if you
hadn't been throwing money at people
begging them to vote for you then then
you wouldn't have had the labor market
disruption
it would have just it would have but
it'll it'll straighten itself out if you
quit throwing money at it and they have
quit i think for now throwing money at
it so it all would be okay but they've
just exasperated everything there's a
vicious cycle there because as things
get more expensive you got to pay people
more in order to afford it and so it
keeps well and so what's happening is
now
with the economy slowing down with a
recession it is receding two quarters in
a row of the gross domestic product
which is the measure of all goods and
services the gdp
two consecutive quarters of it being
smaller is the definition of a recession
so the economy's slowing down
and guess what happens
those companies
they're not selling as much that's the
definition of an economy slowing down
and guess what happens when they don't
sell as much they start laying people
off and guess what happens they don't
have as much profit and so wall street
looks over there and goes you're not as
profitable and stock's down 20 since the
first year now we've got a bear market
to add to this mess
and it's all cause these dubers won't
keep their fingers out of the pie
just back off bozo
let the thing do its thing
that's all you got to do
the economy isn't a magical thing
because it's a bunch of individuals all
acting in their own best self-interest
long-term and short-term and people have
generally pretty good thoughts out there
so
the raise of the fed what's it do
uh it's the cost that one bank loans
money to another bank it's the interest
rate
so the interest that banks charge is
going to go up
oh wait a minute credit cards didn't go
up because it was already 18
how much they're not going to raise it
to 18 and three-quarter okay so what is
going to go up
car loans
they'll be more expensive student loan
which is interest rates could go up
if you if you if you're currently
sitting with if you're not going to go
borrow money
on
something other than a credit if you've
got a student loan it's fixed if you got
a mortgage it's fixed even if you've got
a car loan it's fixed but if you're
going to go buy a new car it's probably
going to be a higher interest rate
a month from now than it would have been
four months ago and if you've got an
offer we would have told you not to do
that anyway stupid you don't borrow
money on a car you pay cash for it okay
so it doesn't affect ramsey listeners
because you don't have credit cards you
bet you're paying off the debt that
you've got you're not going to go to a
bank and borrow money the fed rate does
not cause mortgage rates
mortgage rates are caused by the bond
market now it influences it we like
relationship there typically mortgage
rates follow the fed rate but it
mechanically is not connected it's
simply what banks loan to another bank
it's the wholesale cost of money between
two banks
and so it doesn't cause mortgage rates
mortgages are packaged together and sold
on the bond market so whatever the bond
market is doing is what drives mortgage
rates but it usually follows it and
guess what a bear market
stocks going down generally what happens
to bonds they go up
so that's going to actually help maybe
offset it
it's a very complicated thing thank you
for this question the point is none of
you need to panic
just sit back and watch the circus well
what's fun about
my monkeys my circus
you know just sit back and watch the
circus you know i'm not in let's get
popcorn while we're at it i'm not going
to participate in your all's craziness
i'm going to watch you all it's great
don't do it you see you guys are going
to be okay turn off the news because
they're gonna cause you to panic they're
peddling fear porn this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org
budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
so
[Music]
well imagine an energy the energy of a
jam-packed arena filled with people
ready to experience what it means to
live life to the fullest
all the ramsey personalities are going
to be there it's called the smart
conference
georgia will be speaking
i'll be speaking rachel cruz dr john
deloney ken coleman christina ellis
we're going to be talking about of
course money of course leadership of
course marriage and craig groeschel amy
groschel from life church are going to
come and teach on marriage
we're going to be talking of course
about career and about mental wellness
from dr john we're going to cover
everything it's a day-long event when
you leave you will be
smarter that's why it's called the smart
conference pretty simple saturday
october 22nd in dallas it is about 35
sold out there'll be about 8 000 folks
there so you still got time to get your
tickets there a whole 39
with this lineup we should charge 390
dollars but we don't so
visit ramseysolutions.com
events and get your tickets and come
visit us in dallas it's going to be a
lot of fun we're also doing four
building wealth events in the fall
they are all 85 to 90 sold out almost
gone so be sure and check those out uh
and make sure you plan on coming to one
of those cities our question of the day
comes from blinds.com find out for
yourself why blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best deal today's question comes from
james in wyoming he says i'm 28 years
old and i'm on baby step 3. i'm looking
ahead to baby step 4 where my fiance and
i will invest 15 of our income into
retirement what are your thoughts on
dividend investing i was thinking after
the house has paid off the only thing
better than no payments is having
passive income from our investments
covering our living expenses i want to
achieve this before the age of 60 when
we can start withdrawing from our
retirement is this a good way to
allocate our 15
and if so how does receiving a dividend
work with a roth ira is it still taxed
great questions from a 28 year old i'm
impressed oh very good very good well a
dividend paying investment would be a
typically what's called a blue chip
company a large company
okay like a general motors okay
they're not usually very exciting in
their price changes
uh up or down uh but they make a lot of
money and so when they make money and
when you own a share of stock you're one
of the owners of the company
you own a tiny little piece of the
company when you own one share of
general motor stock if they make a
profit and they decide to distribute
that profit to the owners that's called
a dividend and so a dividend paying
investment would typically be large
company stocks that are paying out their
profits
and are fairly predictable on that and
people buy them for that and that only
uh if that's in a roth ira the dividends
stay inside the roth ira until you're 59
and a half it's tax-free like anything
else is
but um
and what you would just flip the
dividends and they reinvest back into
more stock is what happens inside of
that you cannot pull anything out of a
roth ira before 59 and a half without
getting penalized and taxed
and so we're not going to use that for
something to get to early and i really
wouldn't do it
i just i if you if you want to invest
i would just do 15 of your income into
the four types of mutual funds we talk
about growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international if
that gets too big and you're getting
close to 50 years old and you don't have
any money to support you between 55 and
60 or 50 55 and 59 and a half then you
might just start with something like
some index funds and that's called
bridge investing at that point which is
a taxable brokerage account where you
just invest and it's all it's going to
be taxed when you take it out but
actually it's a taxable mutual fund yeah
that's what it is so with your roth ira
just leave it in there it'll be
reinvested it'll still help your money
grow but i wouldn't worry about this as
a passive income strategy yeah you've
been you've been reading too many
websites passive income is great when
you're in retirement and you get the
passive income from that investment from
that roth ira and it's a tax-free income
you don't need passive income
um
and so
and typically these are the the calmest
of the four types okay the growth growth
in income it's a growth in income type
stock that would be a dividend and
income part and that that's a those blue
chip big
dinosaur companies and it's the least
exciting
the least uh
rate of return it's the lowest rate of
return of the four types we talk about
and that i owe so i'm 61. i did none of
what you're talking about all i did was
buy real estate that i pay cash for and
invest in those four types of mutual
funds in my 401k that's and really
that's really all you need to do if you
you know up to
tens of millions i mean you don't need
to get fancy it's won't make you a
billionaire but uh but you won't be
broke and you'll be a millionaire and a
multi-millionaire you'll end up
somewhere in between absolutely ryan is
in tampa hey ryan welcome to the ramsey
show
hello gentlemen thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up
well my wife and i are in our early 50s
the past 12 10 12 years have been pretty
tough we got hammered in 2008 and we're
both self-employed
um on top of the home just making
we'll just take responsibility for it
making really bad financial decisions
and kind of always being behind eight
ball so
we find ourselves now um not much in
retirement we're not
saving much money we have a house that
needs about
50 to 75 000 in repair but it has
400 000 in equity and so my question to
you
would you borrow against it fix the
house living it
not having again still much in the bank
to do much with or would you sell and
start from scratch
what's wrong with it
uh windows
it's built in the 20s so it's just one
of those homes
what would a sell for today
uh as is
that's that's the tough question
anywhere between eight and eight fifty
you if you repaired it would you like it
and want to stay there
well that's the whole other level
because you know you know your your
wives have that security organ i think
you've talked about in the past my wife
is emotionally attached to this house
it's where we raised our kids and
what's your household income sir
about 150. okay it varies because i'm a
photographer my way say that one's a
small hair salon we got hit pretty hard
with the event industry and cove and
whatnot so we've been still recovering
from that well you ought to be back but
yeah we're
but events and just slow you know just
slow
ain't nothing slow in florida
we did an event down i did two events
down there for 3 000 people just the
other day
all right that's a whole another another
whole another phone call as far as
rebranding remarketing and just trying
to to kind of reinvent at the same time
it's all correlated yes but
no i think your attitude is the biggest
downer in the whole situation
yeah you had the snot beat out of you
and you're tired
um
to say the least yeah and it's it's not
you're not as excited and hopeful about
running a business as you used to be
yeah you're you're really good yeah
you're really good well i've been i'm an
entrepreneur man when you get the crap
beat out of you there's there's days you
just wanna you know the old saying is an
entrepreneur is anybody who can go from
sheer terror to sure exhilaration and
back every 24 hours right
yeah for sure and and the problem is is
you you were already struggling and kind
of limping and then kova just kicked you
in the teeth for about eight more months
and just took all the fun out of all of
this
yeah but i don't want to make excuses
because i didn't hear an excuse i'm just
reading your mail man it's not an excuse
it's just a reality
it is so you guys have any debt ryan
that's the thing we got about 50 grand
in personal debt between cars and credit
cards okay let's pretend something okay
let's pretend i could flip a switch
which i can't right i can't but let's
just play pretend for a second
and
suddenly you were excited and your wife
was excited about your business because
you were wanting to go make a whole
bunch of money with these businesses and
we take this 150 and we jack it up and
we get busy and we work like crazy
people it's like we're excited 18 year
olds or something like we don't know any
better okay
and we go make a bunch of money and we
get get new clients because they see our
enthusiasm and the light in our eyes and
the spark in our step and all that and
you get this thing moving you can make
175. now if you're making 175 000 a year
how long does it take to come up with a
hundred thousand dollars
two years two years yeah i'll help you
two years
one year you're debt-free the next year
you rehab the house
you don't have a house problem
you don't even have an income problem
you've just gotta your gas tank is empty
problem
it's a spiritual thing dude
and i'm not blaming you and i'm not
saying shaming you because i've been
right where you are i kind of felt the
same way part of the time during coven
it was i got it got old man it got real
old
these jerk wads telling everybody what
to do i got sick of them
that alien fouchy oh my god send him
back to whatever planet he was from
unbelievable
but i want you i want you to get after
it
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host thank you for joining us america
you can stop by our ramsey solutions
headquarters we do the show live on the
glass from one to four central time
every day and it's free to attend and
visit our visitor center and get free
chocolate chip cookies and
you can watch the uh the zoo animals
inside the glass perform and it feels
like the whole thing yeah it's it's um
yeah there you go so and also in the
lobby and there's usually 50 to a couple
hundred people somewhere out there
especially this time of year hanging out
and so come hang out with some of your
other friends and get some free coffee
some free cookies and uh some
entertainment that's worth exactly what
you pay for it so there you go on the in
the lobby on the debt free stage allen
and jamie are with us hey guys how are
you guys great welcome where you guys
live mitchell mitchell south dakota
south dakota okay
what part of south dakota it's on the
east side about an hour west of sioux
falls got it okay cool cool nothing flat
out there just complete mountainous
right sure
what do you guys do for a living
she uh we own our own sanitation company
and she works at mooth electric okay yep
i do accounting for an electrical
contracting company there cool how much
debt you pay off we paid off uh 133
960 and 70 cents way to go
and how long did this take 12 months
look at you ding ding and your range of
income during that time about seventy
thousand to about eighty five thousand
okay
my brain hurts yeah
so uh okay so what kind of debt was the
hundred and thirty four thousand uh we
had about thirty five thousand dollars
in student loans um we had some business
debt
uh that was about 62 000 for our garbage
trucks over another repair loan for one
of the garbage trucks for about 21 000
and then a 15 thousand dollars to my
parents
okay but you did not make 135 thousand
during the twelve months so where did
the money come from we sold my rental
houses over in a neighboring town oh
okay yep and so that was a big part of
it there was some savings as well and as
well that helped contribute towards that
so you sold a rental house or two one
one one okay what did it sell for fifty
five thousand oh okay all right so that
was about half of this um not quite not
quite 40 40 of this it definitely helped
yeah that helped a bunch and then you
had some money in savings how much i
honestly can't remember
30-ish something
so that now puts you well up over half
yeah and then you attack the rest of it
now the numbers start to work that's
good yeah yeah yeah you still busted it
this is yeah you still went after it and
it was dramatic change i mean you start
just going wow
you're getting after it so what happened
tell us the story how did you get
connected to ramsay so i started
listening to show to the show february
of 2021 um
at work we can listen to music or
podcasts or whatever so i actually got a
recommendation from a co-worker of mine
um to listen to the ramsey so i started
listening to it and i just became hooked
to it and i started talking to alan
about it i kept talking to him and i
think i pretty much annoyed him into
doing it
but yeah we just i just kept talking
about like we got to do this we got to
do this we got to pay off your loans
like the the interest was um delayed on
it and everything like let's just do it
let's just get it done this is the time
to pay off these student loans and then
for a while we were kind of actually
like ish to be honest um we were doing
most of it right you know and then we
had the um one of our garbage trucks
needed a new motor in it and that was
over twenty thousand dollars and i
got
mad like i was just done i'm done with
this i went and got the second job i um
allen got other jobs and we were just
working working working because i was
just so mad that we had to take out one
more loan i almost felt kind of slimy
actually just because we finally had we
had to do that we had to do that and i
didn't like it and
yeah we just we just got mad and we just
worked and worked and worked and worked
and yeah that's when the rental house
went up for sale yeah yeah we were
actually just in the process of getting
that needed a little bit of work done
before we could um sell it but we went
put that up for sale we were just
selling things left and right i was
going through some of our stuff and just
selling on facebook marketplace whatever
we could do to get any extra dollars we
put every single penny that we had
towards the debt and along with 60 to 70
hours
work weeks yeah you're both working at
least that for a week working like a
wild people yep and now you're now
you're debt-free everything but the
house yep how's that feel fantastic i
remember the day when we paid off the um
the garbage truck says that was the last
biggest loan
we both i swear i think i grew a couple
inches i feel like i lost 20 pounds like
we were just it was it was on
cloud nine for the longest time
and it was just the best feeling in the
world and i looked at him like we are
never doing this ever again and we got
our emergency fund for 36 months
sorry
three to six months emergency fund done
and everything so now we're on baby step
four and six and we're after this trip
when we get home we're gonna start
paying off the house early so
it feels good it feels wow you guys are
impressive
that was an impressive year i mean i'm
exhausted just hearing about it
you guys busted you got sick and tired
and decided we're not gonna ever be in
the situation again nope never again and
now you're running the business
debt-free yes
yeah and then when we paid off the
garbage trucks that's when fuel prices
really started to go up and i remember
when that happened alan was kind of like
what do we do do we raise our prices do
we do this and i'm like wait what hold
on like we don't have this truck payment
anymore let's just
take a deep breath let's see what
happens and we haven't rose prices yet i
hope we don't have to obviously but if
we do we do but
yeah it's just like well we don't have
to do this right now let's just take a
deep breath because we don't have this
debt anymore
yes yeah you make decisions differently
now yes with calmness
yes that makes them better or at least
an extra deep breath
yeah you guys are very very very well
done i'm so proud of you dr john delaney
talks about that your body carries
physically carries the stress and dead
equal stress and so there is truly a
physical release yes when you get out
you do feel a little taller feel a
little lighter yeah because you know
your
muscles are more relaxed you will make
better decisions you sleep a lot better
you do sleep a lot better yes yeah yeah
and you didn't even realize it no yeah
you know didn't even realize it how long
y'all been married it'll be three years
in september okay and so
two years of normal and then a year of
busting it yep and and now you're free
will you ever go back no no no never
again no
yeah way to go you guys y'all are in a
great business by the way
the uh the the data on the business that
you're in uh indicates you're going to
be very wealthy it's a uh
it's a it's a very hard business hard
work it's very hard very hard work and
uh and it's not glamorous no but it's
very it's very profitable and you will
and there's always a need
it's not like this is something people
can do without they gotta have your help
and so you're just it's uh it's real
there's really good numbers on that so
i'm proud of you you gotta you got a
bright bright future we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you how
ordinary people became
extraordinarily wealthy and how you can
too you guys are on your way you're
going to be millionaires before you know
it and also we've got a copy of total
money makeover for you and i'm going to
give you a one-year subscription to
financial peace university get you
signed up for the membership on that and
uh that's a part of ramsey plus of
course and uh if you've done all of that
already and you want to just give it
away to somebody who needs a blessing
you can do that too
we've done that with a friend of ours
already so
that's our gift to you and then you do
with it you re-gift it at your will
we're happy to happy to have you do
either one a lot of people buy financial
peace university and give it as gifts
already so not unusual at all very well
done you two allen and jamie mitchell
south dakota 134 000 paid off in 12
months making 70 to 85.
it all happened when they got mad count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
three
two
one
[Applause]
wow here's what happens when you want
something
so bad that nothing else matters you let
go of the rental house you let go of the
savings you let go of your pride you let
go of your need to impress others you
let go of stuff so you can get the thing
that matters the most
and when you that's what happens that's
exactly what happens when people get mad
they get sick and tired of being sick
and tired they finally say i've had it
and that'll happen i mean with all this
economic crisis i think people are
starting to get mad and going i'm not in
a good financial position if the
pandemic didn't wake up maybe the biden
gimmick will wake you up
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host elliott is in miami hi elliot
how are you
hey i'm doing well how are you all
better than we deserve what's up
i got a question regarding estate
planning and
uh basically which way you guys suggest
to go whether it be a will or a trust
um i have a friend who i'm i'm 30. i've
got a friend who's also around that age
and
his estate planning attorney was pushing
him towards a trust i was under the
impression you only really needed to
trust if you were you know a
gazillionaire type deal so i just wanted
to get your thoughts your impression was
correct
okay okay let's talk it through for a
second you do need a will even if you
have a trust you need a will still okay
and you can get one at
mamabearlegalforms.com what's your net
worth
uh my net worth is right around 750 to
650 depending on what day i look at it
right now
good for you well done awesome okay so
the only thing a trust
an irrevocable trust does for you is the
items
the assets that you retitle after
forming the trust and the trust will
cost about three thousand dollars will
cost 300 to 500.
okay
the only thing the trust does for you
is it it does absolutely nothing on
federal estate tax
you do not have a large enough estate to
be taxed on a federal level the only
thing is each state has
you file probate on your estate when you
die your your heirs would and they file
with the probate court and each state
has a probate tax
typically they're three
percent
two percent something like that i don't
know what florida's is
okay
there's a lot of uh uh
tennessee's is less than two percent
okay
so that's what you would save
on the amount that you put in the trust
you save two percent okay and
yeah and that's actually that's the
reason that the
attorney was pushing them that way you
know essentially saying your kids will
save the money you can
your kids will save the money in the
long run exactly here's the problem
okay whatever you put into that trust
every time you do a transaction with it
you have to involve the trustee it's an
absolute pain in the butt
okay could you expand on that a little
bit yeah every time you do a transaction
on the item that is in the trust it's an
absolute pain in the butt you have to go
get a trustee to sign everything you
can't if you put your house in this
trust you can't sell your house
without involving the trustee
okay they have to come to the closing
they have to do all the stuff they have
to sign the contracts
they have to do everything because you
no longer own the house the trust now
owns the house
and so operationally for a young guy
like you because you're going to do a
lot of deals with these assets
throughout your life operationally
having them all in an irrevocable trust
is an absolute pain in the butt and i
got to tell you my net worth is well in
excess of what is needed for
estate planning on the federal level
hundreds of millions of dollars and i do
not have a trust of the type that we are
talking about because i operationally
even at 62 years old don't want to screw
with if i get ready to sell a piece of
property i don't want to screw with
having to do with all this stuff
so now i do have some trusts in my
estate plan of a different
type and a different ilk but that's more
of a liability yeah but i said
protection you know the truth is i
if i were you i wouldn't do it and and i
haven't done it and mine is and i've got
a lot larger net worth than you so we we
don't recommend spending the extra three
thousand dollars and putting yourself in
a position of all this hassle to save 20
grand
well and when you think about it what
does the estate planning attorney have
to gain well he's going to make 10x
selling you a trust versus getting you a
will and that's like a whole life
insurance salesman well
except that this actually does work sure
you know it's not a crappy product if
it's a two if it's two percent on a
million dollars it saves you 20 saves
your estate 20 grand if you've paid 3
000 to do that that's a fair trade not
counting all the fact that you got to go
through all the freaking hassle of
operating everything this way
and it's just so as he gets older and if
he has a few million dollars and a bunch
of assets that you're not gonna do
anything with you're gonna let it sit
there you're never gonna touch it while
you're alive or you have a piece of
property that you absolutely are never
going to touch while you're alive
you can throw it into a trust and it
won't get you know it won't get probated
so that that's helpful in that regard
but it's a pain
in z but
it says i just i
not a fan not a fan not a fan kevin is
with us in philadelphia hi kevin what's
up
hi thank you so much for taking my call
how are you better than we deserve sir
how can we help
so i am in the process of engaging
engaging or
proposing to my girlfriend next weekend
so i've been
yeah i'm excited um so i've been trying
to save or been saving for a wedding and
stuff for you know our house that we're
probably getting married next year
um
so
right now i own a or not own finance a
toyota camry 21 i owe 32 000
um not too long ago a couple weeks ago i
had to replace the transmission um and
because of that there is a negative
equity of eight thousand dollars
um
i'm thinking
sorry
replacing the transmission does not
cause negative equity
really
yeah your car did not going down in
value because you put a new transmission
in it
oh okay it would go down in value if it
was sitting on the side of the road with
no transmission
but you paid to replace it right
yeah the car is operating just fine
yes transmission was installed by a
reputable firm
yes who told you the car went down in
value because of this
this is this is kind of my
my assumption okay
all right
great news you're wrong
okay good i'm happy
so
the problem is i make only forty
thousand a year and you need to sell a
car right in your office
yeah yeah you need to sell the car but
we need to find out what the cars really
work jump on kellybluebook.com
at kbb.com and put in their private sale
so if you sold it individual to another
individual what you could get for it not
trade in value because you're not going
to trade it you're going to sell it and
how much do you owe on it again
32 000 okay and what'd you say the model
was
it's a toyota camry 21 a 21.
okay i'm gonna guess and say you
probably can get out of it
it'll probably sell for enough to pay it
off
used car markets quite hot still
still a shortage on cars
and i might be wrong but just look it up
see what you can sell it for see what
it'll bring do you have any money kevin
in the bank
um yeah i have about i think ten
thousand dollars saved he's gotta buy an
engagement ring hmm and he's got to get
out of this car
yeah
so we want you get you like a 5 000 car
and get rid of this thing so that you
get your life back because you have no
payments at this point and man you're
going to be able to pile up money so
fast because that car payment stinks man
that's like a 650 car payment in it
yep
couch almost like i've done this before
and once she says yes you have no one to
impress so it doesn't matter if you're
driving a 5 000 car oh and by the way if
she is only impressed with your 32 000
cars she's not the one
yeah you're right
that's fine
congrats man that's exciting stuff yeah
you're getting ready to change your
whole life you're getting ready to be
engaged and no payments life is good for
you yeah get on the line let's figure
out what this car is worth let's get rid
of it brother and get you a little cheap
car that you'll pay cash for and then
save like crazy and move up in car later
you don't have to drive a hooptie the
rest of your life but you need to be
driving one right now so you can get
your life back
because right now car companies taking
toyota's taking all your money
i'm just shocked that a year old camry
had the transmission go out
that's pretty wild you know what that's
a good point we're like is that an under
warranty there ought to be a factory
warranty yeah an extended warranty on
but he said he paid for it so too late
now but
who knows i'd look into that though for
sure yeah too late i'm fighting that
probably too late what drives me crazy
though is people going well dave you
can't find a car for under 15 000 right
now there's no clunkers listen i go to
auto trader i do sort by lowest price to
highest and there's plenty of cars are
they beautiful no
do they work just fine barely
it'll get you around you'll be okay and
they they're going for three four five
there's still cheap cars out there but
you're not going to impress anyone
driving down the road with it give it a
fancy name call rusty yeah
old bluebird did you have any names for
any ear clunkers oh yeah they all had
names were they female i feel like
that's kind of the thing for guys yeah
no i had i had the one that was bondo
colored and we called it bluebird oh i
like that
because they're kind of like blue color
bondo yeah yeah makes it prettier not
sure what the real color was because it
was mainly repairs
it was just duct tape it was a failing
wire really ugly when i drive a nice car
now i just remember old blue bird and i
figure i drove like no one else so now i
can drive like nowhere there it is this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work they
love and create actual
amazing relationships thank you for
joining us george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five
two two five well george there's a
couple of uh very interesting things
have happened in the uh
world of crypto oh yeah uh this one so
we've seen the big the big crash dave
and we've we've talked about billion
dollars lost in crypto scams but the
latest is that the crypto market has now
lost two
trillion dollars in value
uh and this is from yahoo finance
investors had nowhere to hide on monday
as both the stock market and
cryptocurrencies tumbled the crypto
market saw its total market cap drop by
roughly 12 percent on monday to just 980
billion the sector as a whole has now
seen more than two trillion dollars in
losses since its peak back in november
wow
so it's down what now 60 something
percent since september
that's a big hit and people are people
have been coming at me dave because you
know i've been making fun little videos
about crypto and they're saying well
what about the stock market well what
about the stock market this stuff's down
65 percent the stock market's down 20
can't you add no
the answer is no
what about the stock market it has a
70-year track record what's crypto got a
track record of you losing your butt
well the stock market is based on actual
companies that are producing actual
things that's a huge difference that
we're not talking about
crypto is just based on what one guy is
willing to pay for it and it produces
nothing which is why warren buffett
famously uh recently said that he
wouldn't write 24 it actually crashed
yeah he said i wouldn't pay 25 dollars
for all of it
and now
and he actually
he may have overpaid if this keeps up
that's true he might be able to buy it
all for 25 at this point oh wow
and listen in case you were afraid that
this was going to be a problem
uh the
twitter co-founder and block ceo jack
dorsey
and rapper jay-z both known for their
financial prowess that's right
um are going to save you
they're going to take great care of you
because they have now opened the bitcoin
academy for children
yikes is that a real sentence that's a
brand new sentence
no one has ever said that a spokesperson
for the bitcoin academy confirmed to fox
business that the curriculum will
include topics such as what is money
and go on what else is there dave
[Music]
you have to pick this up george i can't
get my composure so they cover topics
such as what is money what is
cryptocurrency what is blockchain and
how to keep yourself safe from scammers
oh boy this is the financial literacy
the kids have been needing dave
teaching five-year-olds about blockchain
um
wow the in-person classes will be hosted
two evenings a week and serve
participants dinner a crypto kids camp
program will also take place on two
saturdays for macy marcy kids and teens
ages 5-17 the academy will provide
participants with mifi devices and a
one-year limited data plan plus
smartphones if needed oh good good give
the kids internet and smartphones and
load them up with crypto i think that
dinner might be worth more than the
crypto
this is scary it might be worth it just
for the dinner at this point
crypto kids camp those are three words i
never wanted the truth is these two guys
really are trying to do something good
and they have no idea how dumb this is
yes i love them
they're not bad guys they're just trying
to help somebody but
and they're actually you know teaching
something they believe which the problem
with that is it's just wrong
not wrong morally but just just
factually and of course the article ends
with the academy's launch comes amid a
volatile time for the cryptocurrency
market well if anything hope the kids
learn a lesson
wow this is fascinating well if we've
learned anything from the but we did we
did discover this week that dave ramsey
actually agrees
with the ceo
of a crypto company this headline after
potentially that is a headline
ramsey agrees with a c with a crypto ceo
someone pick that up if you're listening
right there that's a twitter headline
well it comes from this dave the chances
of me agreeing with crypto anything's
probably really close to zero
oh yeah but i do completely agree with
this guy on a leadership standpoint
let's be clear well we do we have to
clarify clarify that matters marketwatch
said after petition for leadership
changes coinbase ceo tells workers to
quit if they don't believe in top execs
so there's been this big petition also
shouldn't work for some in a place where
you don't agree with leadership or you
don't trust them you don't trust
leadership that's what he said
which is exactly what i have said from
the stage here in ramsey i tell our
people that all the time don't let the
butt don't let the door hit you in the
butt well and you've also said that no
cults tell you to do that so that which
is a true statement yeah
wow that's uh um
yeah so
yeah
that's
that's a wonderful thing yeah that i
love his reaction to that and by the way
like three days later when crypto dove
they laid off 25 of their employees so
probably the dude that put out the
petition for the ceo's head got fired
um which if they had discovered him
they'd have fired him too and they
should have because listen if you're so
backward that you think
listen if you if you're a better leader
than your leader is go start something
leave go start something
you don't get to tell him how to run his
deal
that's not that's his deal i'm not going
to tell him how to run this deal i'm
going to tell you not to buy his product
because it's crypto but but i'm going to
tell him how to run his deal
that i just love that
it's um
yeah that was a good answer dude glad we
found some middle ground between you and
we found something that i agree on yeah
found something we agree on you got
everybody's got something they agree on
you never know yeah apparently our hair
care products are similar me and you no
him oh okay he's bald guys just for the
record yeah just just just i got excited
i was like dave what are you using these
days this is great this is big news to
me you got excited we use the same
pomade george you just get too excited
too easily all right
it's with us in grand rapids hey brandon
what's up
good afternoon gentlemen how are you
great man how can we help
um i'm about to start a new job and it
is state employment which means that it
comes with some good retirement benefits
um i wanted to hear your opinion because
there's two separate options that i'm
able to choose
okay which one what are they
well i want to preface it by saying that
i think i remember you saying before
that you would normally choose a
standard savings plan 401k over a
pension almost always
yes so the reason i'm calling is because
when i got the sheet that shows the two
options one of the options was called a
pension plus two plan
so the first plan is just the defined
contribution plan which is savings only
it's a 401k
and then there's a pension plus plan
that supposedly pairs the same benefits
but also a pension
and normally it would have a straight
life option which is what you would
avoid
but it also contains a survivor option
and that so that it has a reduced
pension yeah so how much if you don't
take the pension you can just do a 401k
yes and how much they give you how much
they give you in that case
i'm not 100 sure yet well that would
matter because the pension they are
funding 100
and usually if you don't do the pension
and you do the 401k they give you a big
sweet match
and i'd want to know what that is
because they they're going to have cost
either way they're trying to push people
towards 401ks these days i would push it
towards the 401 incentivizing them with
the match yeah exactly
and i
i don't think you're going to run the
numbers in a way brandon that's going to
make you not do the 401k i don't think
it's going to happen
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at
blinds.com blinds.com makes it simple to
shop top quality blinds shades and
interior shutters from home with easy
online ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a lot of our calls on the show lately
have been about the crazy real estate
market the pandemic
rising inflation and gas prices
fear of recession the bear market
more than ever people need hope
with their money
maybe you're feeling that way
well that's why you need financial peace
university
this isn't your dad's version of fpu
though we just did a massive update to
our biggest and most famous money course
it's still our proven principles but
refreshed
for what you're facing today
you're going to hear from me of course
and rachel of course now dr john daly
and george campbell are going to bring
their fresh insights and show you new
ways to look at your money if you're
feeling scared or overwhelmed you're not
alone
there's a lot going on out there
but most of it you can't control the
only thing you can control is you and
you can take control of you and your
money
and your stress will go down
and your fear will go down
that's why we call it financial
peace
university
you can start fpu for free check out all
the new content by visiting
ramseysolutions.com
fpu that's ramseysolutions.com
fpu george the new lessons in this are
really good the team did an incredible
job and uh me and john deloney we tag
team the y spending lesson the old buyer
beware which was a fan favorite reworked
it retooled it
it's the best it's ever been as a matter
of fact the whole course
is head and shoulders the best it's ever
been we just launched all the new videos
about a week ago yeah and i did baby
step three as well and both lessons uh
coincidentally you're talking about
finding peace and getting control that's
what both those lessons are about baby
step three is where you really start to
feel the financial peace kick in and
getting control in a world where you're
constantly bombarded with marketing
messages telling you you're not enough
here's how you should be spending your
money this is the key to freedom man we
just kind of sort through all the noise
and i give you a plan on how to become a
smart spender there is a lot out there
to be afraid of right now
and um
a lot of different people's buttons are
being pushed in different ways
on all these all this economic news and
the truth is that fear
is not
a good decision-making tool
panic is an even worse decision-making
tool
and it's when you do the dumbest things
when you are functioning in fear your
les your lizard brain kicks in and your
critical thinking skills disappear
your critical thinking skills return
when you pan back and you keep
perspective and what gives you the
ability to do that is knowledge
the more you know about something the
more the game slows down
and you can play
and it seems like you're in the matrix
and you can just dodge the bullets right
yeah and you don't fall for all the
traps out there when you're a calm level
header you're not doing the 401k loan
and the heloc and buying out pay later
because you know better now it's just
you know when you
how many times have i talked to somebody
over the years including myself in the
mirror and the dumbest things i've ever
done or right after i got desperate and
scared
i mean that's just before you get really
stupid you're scared
just before you get really stupid you're
desperate
and the one the king will keep you from
doing that and reacting
to all the news instead of making a
decision because here's the thing
i mean let's use the bear market as an
example okay then bear more the bear is
here okay the definition of a bear
market's a 20 drop
and the stock market's down more than 20
it's probably down 21 today total since
the first year okay
now what does that mean
have you lost everything no
it means if you had a hundred thousand
dollars and you were retired you already
didn't have enough
and instead of 100 you have 80.
if you had a million dollars and you
retired
uh instead of a million you have 800.
really doesn't affect your life much
it really doesn't
but it affects your emotions a lot and
here's the other thing
the there's been 14 bear markets
since world war ii wow
okay
the average length of a bear market is
13 months
the average recovery time is 24 months
two years
okay
so when will it be back to where it was
in january
on average two years
and that's happened 14 times
and you lived through them all since
world war ii
yep i didn't live through all of them
but i lived through several of them yeah
thank you george but that wasn't an ace
joke i did not mean to go there no but
it happened too late you just stumbled
right into it but yeah tell us about the
40s dave yeah tell us about the 50s and
the 40s
that was a twinkle in my daddy's eye but
yeah what you're trying to say is
perspective helps uh so yeah there you
go for a lot of us this might be the
first one we're experiencing
it does give because that's the thing if
you're um
you know if you're in your 20s
um
this is the first economic downturn for
you as an adult
because 2008 you were a baby child
okay so this is your first one
and so if you're 26 and you're freaking
out
it's because it's your first car wreck
i've had several car wrecks and so now i
just get out and we exchange licenses
and call the cops
as long as nobody's hurt we're okay
right and so you know but the first time
you have one it's like oh god yeah
you're ready
you know right and it's it's it's
traumatic so but when when tragedy or
trauma or
uh
something comes at you and it activates
fear it shuts your brain's ability down
to do critical thinking skills so let's
pretend the market's down 20 the big bad
bears out okay now the bear is here and
what are we going to do with the bear
okay now here think about it all right
if the average there's 14 of them that's
a pretty good data set and the average
is 24 months back so where are you going
to be in 24 months
24 months older
even if you're 68 you'll just be 70.
if you're 24 you're going to be 26 and
it's going to be back
so your 100 your 80 will be 100 again
your 800 will be a million again
that's the average and what will it be
five years from now
it'll be way up five years from now
these are the averages
so when you pan back and you go okay
when it drops it generally comes back
like has every time
a hundred percent of the time it is
recovered
all the time it's always gone up from
there so if you're looking at if you're
26 and you're looking out there to 66
you're not really worried about what it
does until you get out there
and there's no time in history that it's
gone more than five years without making
money zero except the great depression
and this is not the great depression
there's some great stupidity going on in
washington but it's not the great
depression it's different
and so just way different it's a
completely different set of facts and
data and processes
and yet people's get their emotions
kicked in and here's what's very
interesting to me george like we posted
this thing on instagram about what was
happening with housing oh yeah you know
all the haters that blew up yeah all the
haters come out so you went viral but um
yeah i i i've
i'm i am well anyway but the uh
things i do so whatever use your filter
not since covet but yeah um
but anyway the uh uh
when people that are intellectual
become afraid
it's very interesting that the
way their stupidity manifests
is intellectually
they come up with these bizarre
layered arguments to prove that the
world is coming to an end because their
emotions have already decided that the
world is coming to an end instead of
panning back and actually being calm and
looking at the data and looking at the
historical
precedents that are there and keeping
perspective when they're doing this if
you pan back and do all that you just
your little butt calms down
that's what it amounts to because if in
perspective you know what's going on and
that makes all the difference in the
world you find whatever you're looking
for and if you look at the data and go
well the world is coming to an end
it might be for you in your mind and you
will intellectually fight for your right
to be
to be right about the world coming to an
end and you'll bring everyone down with
you around you real fun at parties and
you know here's the horrible thing is it
makes you a commenter
on instagram which is the lowest form of
life when you what about twitter you
didn't even have something to say you
had to comment on something someone else
said i mean this is like you've really
hit bottom honey when you are when the
only thing you have to do is to comment
on instagram you truly have they think
that's the only thing in their control
is that how many times i have commented
on instagram zero no no once i no i said
pretty baby
nice dog oh wow is that on my instagram
stuff like that no you don't have a baby
you have a nice dog thank you but yeah
but the i mean great little frenchies
you're saying you've only commented
positive things well i mean it's more
like you know my friend's got his little
kid out there water skiing and i'm like
that's awesome because your mom and todd
you got nothing nice to say don't say
nothing at all don't comment but i'm not
gonna get in there and argue with some
dupe i don't even know with no username
be wrong in the comments section it's so
embarrassing i wouldn't want to do that
bless you all's hard
seriously leave that to me dave i'll
handle the comment section
[Music]
okay
that's what the block button was
invented for today
first ever just for you this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsay right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions tom and
kim are with us on the debt-free stage
t-shirts say living financially peaceful
i love it well done well done all right
how much you paid off guys
we paid off a hundred and twenty eight
565
and we did it in three years and two
days way to go way to go
and your range of income in that three
years and two days when we started we
were at about 138 000 uh by the end 179
cool what do y'all do for a living
i'm an operations manager for a
commercial distributor
and i'm an hr assistant manager for an
auto part manufacturer excellent where
and you guys live where
plainfield illinois it's about an hour
southwest of chicago okay cool cool well
welcome to nashville what kind of debt
was the 129 000
uh you name it
student loans personal loans um some
medical bills two cars credit cards um
401k loan
wow you know what kind of we have it all
you were normal yeah
and normal sucks yeah yeah way to go
guys okay how long y'all been married
eight years okay so five years in the
marriage or so
yeah you look up and you went oh crap
something's got to change tell me your
story how did you get connected to
ramsey and what did you do yeah so it
actually started about a year before we
actually really got on board
um we were you know going through just
living normally you know if we could
afford afford the payments then we could
afford something
um we had an excellent i love debt score
you know and we're real proud
um and we were just fighting all the
time about money and yeah
yeah
i love it yeah cool yeah we came a long
way
so um
i had i think we had probably our 500th
money fight and um i had added my uh
added the total money makeover to my
christmas list
and then um tom ended up buying it for
me so you know there's our sign almost
in spite yeah yeah here right yes yeah
yeah so wait a minute what were you all
fighting about what was the obviously
there was a lot of stress there were a
lot of it was was on time paying the
bills and we weren't on the same page we
weren't communicating we weren't doing
it together
um and it was but he wasn't doing it
right i mean what was the problem
he didn't i wanted to spend it and he
didn't want to spend it oh okay that was
the fight that's what i thought okay all
right yeah yeah now we're coming clean
the tension builds and so he did throw
that total money makeover book at you
and said great yes he did he did which
is really not a good way to get you to
read it
well i actually i did get on board and i
read it
um a couple months after after he got it
for me for christmas i was on maternity
leave i read it um we decided all right
let's do this we got our envelopes we
got our budget we paid off a couple of
the small debts all right um and then we
decided you know what let's do a really
quick solution let's sell our house oh
yeah
so we uh we decided to sell our house
we listed our house that was you know we
were not even ready to to do this um we
got it ready we went um
tom got a second job
and in that same week i went back to
work from maternity leave he got a
second job and we put an offer in on a
house and it was accepted and we had no
offers accepted on our house we hadn't
even listed it yet
and so there was so much anxiety and
stress around the entire situation
so um
we were the opposite of peaceful
and we um
so we were like let's just get through
this and um you know after just having
my daughter i was diagnosed with
postpartum depression and anxiety and
that led to a lot of stress there
um so
we uh we finished with the house ended
up it worked out 10 out of 10 do not
recommend following our story please
don't do what we did so you did get it
sold and you didn't buy the other one we
got it sold and we bought the other one
i don't know how but it all came through
um but we go into this new house we have
you know no emergency fund we're not
we're not ready at all and about four
days later
i went to the doctor for a lump
four weeks later i found out it was
thyroid cancer about four weeks after
that i had surgery and um you know about
four weeks after that i had uh
um you know my
treatment for the the cancer and so it
was about four to five months of just
kind of crazy you know doctor's
appointments and you know whatever we
did have on the side or expected to get
from the house was now going to these
medical expenses
um so we kind of slipped into a point
where it was like you know why us and
why me and will we let's get dinner
because we deserve this you know or you
know throwing out the cancer card or
something sure um
so then about um a few months after that
things kind of settled with that storm
and um i started listening to the
podcast after downloading it like three
months before i finally listened to it
and i listen to it every day on my
commute
to and from work and i was like tom we
have to do this we have to get back on
it and this time
we have to do it together and so we
um we signed up for financial peace we
went through that together he read the
total money makeover so that we were on
the same page um and it was just a
different
vibe going through it together
and when we um you know we were in the
middle of financial peace and i found
out i had to have another surgery and
this time it wasn't panic this time it
was okay that's all right we we can do
this so we um
it really just kind of changed our
mindset when we were doing this together
and we were doing that peacefully so wow
how you doing now good yeah i'm real
good cancer in the rearview mirror yup
yup cancer free yep cancer free for how
long
um it's been
about two years wow since they were able
to say like persians are free praise god
that's awesome
that is so awesome that's the important
part of the story right there yeah yeah
yeah we get to keep you around that's
what we want that's first choice worry
about that stuff later first we got to
keep you around right yeah good good job
wow
wow you're a warrior i mean with all
that stuff you went through and and then
and you're the one the whole time saying
keep at it yeah i mean you guys busted
it and it sounds like this cancer was
kind of the wake-up call that got you
guys on the same page and you went this
is scary and we want if we can control
anything it's our money yeah we can't
control all life circumstances but we
can get our butts in order when it comes
to our finances but this is real um
i mean you went from
really tense
in every part of your life to relaxed
yep and peaceful that shirt has a whole
lot more meaning now yeah living hundred
percent actually peaceful yeah that's
what it does what do you tell people the
key to getting out of that is
commitment
yeah i guess you gotta buy in you gotta
stick to it i guess in this case for
sure yeah and being intentional and
communicating you know even if you're
kind of anxious about the conversation
or something you want to buy you know
just talk with your partner and just be
be communicating how's it feel to be
free oh great so free i mean you're
cancer-free dead free amazing so that's
like two for two right there and
probably fight free has there been a lot
of money fights since becoming debt-free
no no wow no but the first but the first
five years lots of fights lots of them
yes all the time wow so cool yeah that's
a transformation
yeah you were normal and now you're not
be not conformed to this world you don't
want to be normal
but be transformed by the renewing of
your minds well done y'all
well done you're amazing absolutely
powerful all right we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you that's the
next chapter in your story you're
definitely going to be that
and of course in addition to that a
total money makeover book and a one-year
subscription to financial peace
university with the brand new classes
you want to go through it you can or you
can give it to somebody since you guys
have been through it let's bring the
kiddos up what are their names and ages
aiden who's six and emma who's four all
right and it says financial peace baby
on each t-shirt i like it well done guys
oh they're good-looking i love it that's
so fun
well done well done all right it's aidan
and emma and kim and tom from the
chicago area 129 000 paid off in three
years and two days making 138 to 179
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream you're ready three two
one
the littles have been practicing i like
it
wow
oh
wow a lot of drama
that one takes your breath away right
there
man i love freedom
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you for joining us america george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host
i just had one of the guys in our real
estate department that works with all
the real estate agents send me a graph a
second ago i thought this was very
interesting george and i are looking at
it at the break
so okay
for the last
many many many years up until the
pandemic
lumber ran an average of i'm pulling
this graph here i don't even know what
this is 572. so 572 something's
what is that
i don't know what it's based on okay
five but it's lumber was basically
didn't go up
it was sitting at this 572 baseline i
don't know i guess it's
per board foot or whatever
and
then of course it was a shortage of
lumber because the lumber factory shut
down
during quarantine
and lumber went over double
in uh
is it the high point was may of 21. wow
okay so a year ago that triple yeah uh
no it's triple triple triple
it tripled
now today
it is back down
to 568.
so lumber is priced today
about what it has been priced for the
last 10 years
after having shot up triple and come
back down
now that enters into what it costs to
build a house by the way the number one
line item
if you're building a house in your
budget is the lumber cost not counting
labor labor is your biggest cost but uh
your number one line item materials wise
is the lumber package because that's the
biggest part of the home
structurally
unless you're building an unusual home
but i mean a typical home built in
america the lumber cost is your biggest
item
in there in a normal build which has
shot up the price of new construction so
i went up 3x
during pandemic quarantine shortages
and now is back to normal
that's a good sign okay that's an
example of
the
pandemic shortages working themselves
out over time
shortages of cars
drives price up shortages of baby
formula drives the price up shortages of
dot dot dot builds the price up but when
it comes back is when the the supply
comes back up to meet the demand and
once the lumber factory's got the supply
going again it's normalized it's calmed
down it's back down so that element of
inflation isn't there anymore
so inflation's killing us
the part that was created by the
pandemic
shortages the quarantine created
shortages
the economic suppression created by
fouchy where we shut down the economy
and create all these problems with
production so there were shortages of
everything drove the price up that
created was a big factor in this current
inflationary cycle
it had nothing to do with interest rates
it had nothing to do with the white hot
economy it had to do with shortages
shortages always drop prices up well the
shortages are redeeming themselves the
supply is now equaling the demand in a
whole lot of these areas of the world
whole lot of these commodities like
lumber this is a good sign it's very
hopeful sign so it's going to help
normalize the housing market yeah so and
the same thing starting that is going to
happen and the recession is going to
push it over the edge
on the labor labor cost is going to come
back down it's shot up artificially but
suddenly when you can't get a job the
good thing's going to come back down
okay
and and then the last piece will be
energy and that's going to have to do
with biden turning the spigot back on
and doing domestic production again
because otherwise he's going to his
whole party is going to lose every seat
they've ever had if he doesn't do this
because nothing will get you thrown out
of office politically faster than a bad
economy people get pissed off when you
guys with their wallets with that yeah
it's a bad idea so i think we're going
to be okay boys and girls jason's in
portland oregon hey jason what's up
hey dave hey thanks for taking my call
sure um
yeah i just had a question for you i
need some advice here so um i'm 49 years
old
i'm single i've been divorced now about
14 months and i'm just kind of in a new
season in my life kind of starting over
and um i'm i'm looking right now to
possibly purchase a home
um i have seven i have seventy thousand
dollars in savings um i'm thinking of
doing that and but the other option i
think about i really want to get debt
free um i have a i have a car
right now it's a
21 uh toy camry oh 28 000 on it what do
you make and uh uh what do i make per
year uh one little over a hundred
thousand okay
george
well i absolutely think your second
option is the right one for you i want
you to become completely debt free with
a fully funded emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses and then i
want you focusing on the down payment so
the question is how quickly can you do
that and what it's going to what will it
take
yeah i mean and that's kind of my line
of thinking too i mean i i want to pay
off this car loan i mean i could i could
do it
do it today what's stopping you yeah
when you hang up pay it off
and then the other question is do you
keep it
i might rather have a house and a
hooptie
[Laughter]
waiting to save up a down payment and
renting and driving a nice car
right it's up to you but i might do that
especially if i was single my wife
wasn't there to gripe about it
right right
i mean i mean give me advice
i don't need a fancy car i mean i would
like just to pay this thing off what's
it worth if you sold it today
oh gosh uh it's i i would guess
30 20
um because the guy just called in and he
had a twenty one
yeah see but i drive a lot for my job so
my miles are pretty high up there i
would say it's probably around you know
26 27.
so you what it's worth here's the thing
here let's just play okay two options
right one you pay the car off and you
set your emergency fund aside and then
it takes you six months to build up a
down payment for a house and so you buy
a house you know christmas or whatever
right
okay
that's option one option two is you sell
the car and you put a drive a five
thousand dollar car and you buy a house
now
and at christmas you save up and buy a
better car
right
i'll probably do that one
yeah
yeah that's that sounds like a good plan
i like that because interest rates on
your mortgage might be higher at
christmas than they are now
uh-huh they're trending up
right
so uh
i don't know but that
and and the point is i don't want you to
drive you make 100 000 you don't need to
drive a hooptie the rest of your life
but if you drove one for six months or a
year and it got you into a house six
months or a year faster
and you beat the curve on some of these
real estate weirdness that's out there
i mean don't go pay too much for a house
they're not desperate here but you know
go get you a nice condo man in portland
oregon that's a cool place to live
right i mean you might not even want a
house you might want something where you
want to do the maintenance so you can
enjoy enjoy the freedom of you know
being single again and all that kind of
stuff
that's what i like this plan show you
how down that car uh yeah i'm definitely
seeing i think you could sell for 30 or
more in this market still
so i would uh definitely look at so that
pays for the other car i mean that means
you got 70 grand clear because you got
enough out of this car to get another
car
above what you owe on it
so you got 70 grand clear you set 20
side for emergency fund 50 000 for your
down payment on the house let's go get a
house
i
you know
neither one of these plans jason is in
the stupid column
either one is fine it's just a matter of
preference but the beauty of buying now
is um
you could get a better interest rate on
the mortgage than you'll get in
christmas
and if mortgage rates go down you can
always refinance
but um
and you have to worry about that with
cars because you're going to pay so if
i'm wrong you know if i'm wrong and
rates don't go up between on christmas
you just refinance if you get they go
down
i hope they go down
but yeah but it's looking at the
priorities and opportunity costs going
well if i drive a 30 000 car well i
might have to wait longer to get into
this house you do have to wait longer
mathematically because you need to be
debt-free have an emergency fund and a
down payment
period before you buy a house if you're
gonna do that then put it on a 15-year
fixed rate
where the payments no more than a fourth
year take-home pay
ah jason if i'm in your shoes i am
selling the car
and buying me a hooptie and buying a
house this summer
right now and no hurry no rush don't
panic and pay too much for the house you
don't need to get in a bidding war with
some crazy goob
just go find slip around find you a good
deal i hope these bidding wars i think
they're over dave right we can't i think
they are i've seen that part calm down
which is good it would not make me mad
if they were gone forever
the bidding wars it was not good for the
real estate market and not good for the
psyche of the american public buying a
house
not good at all
and we have the largest group of home
buyers in american history
sitting at 35 years old they're called
millennials
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
america george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host open phones at
825-5225
will is in tallahassee hi will how are
you hey dave i'm doing fine how about
yourself better than i deserve sir
what's up in your world
so me and my wife are wanting to buy a
house but we've got about thirty
thousand dollars in debt right now
eighteen thousand is in student loans
and then twelve thousand is in a uh new
car zero percent interest on
and
we don't wanna add to our debt
but my question is with the government
talking about maybe some student loan
forgiveness even though i don't agree
with it
uh would we be better off saving money
instead of paying on the student loans
right now or should we go ahead and
start paying on those loans yeah i'm
gonna go ahead and start paying and not
because i agree or disagree because i
want you to control your life and have
agency over it which you have and you
know the zero percent car loan which you
mentioned i mean that's where student
loans are at and you don't want to keep
the car loan around do you
no i mean we don't want either one well
there we go you answered your own
question so i'm going to attack this
using the debt snowball method so list
all your debts smallest to largest if
the loans are split out just list them
all out there and attack the smallest
one first make minimum payments on the
rest and that's going to be your fastest
way to see progress on this debt and get
to that house eventually
so will here's the thing
if you just
all politics aside let's look at the
actual facts
of what has gone down and it helps you
analyze this okay
the government talking about forgiving
the student loans as a vague general
statement is not the way you should view
this
what you want to watch is this and so
this is fairly easy to predict here's
what's happening okay when president joe
biden was running for president one of
the things he talked about the whole
time was when he got to office to
forgive student loans
you remember that yes sir okay he's been
in office two years
have they done anything
towards get forgiving student loans
actually done
i'm not talking about talk i'm talking
about actually
where there has there been any
legislation introduced any executive
orders has he done
anything
answer no
no
okay now
he's in trouble
politically right now
because the economy's going down the
economy will get you thrown out of
office faster than anything else and all
those people with the same letter after
their name is yours so anybody's got a d
right now is in trouble
when it comes to the fall okay
this is just facts it's not political
analysis it's just common sense
so 100 chance
that he's going to start talking very
loudly about giving about forgiving
student loans between now and october
100 chance he's going to announce
something that sounds good but when you
read the details is going to be nothing
it's going to be complete political
fluff and it'll be somewhere in the
month of september because he's got to
do something to try to prop up the
democrats as they go into the fall
elections because they're going to get
slaughtered based on this economy
right okay in other words it's all bs
it's all political bs
and it and i i'm old okay
100 of the good things that have
happened to me
none of them came from washington dc
in my entire life
if you're waiting to have a good life on
something that comes from the white
house you're gonna have a life that
sucks
so you should just go ahead and fix your
own life george said it a different way
he said take agency over your own life
you take control plus as you said
all three of us are saying
well you me and george you signed the
paper you owe the money you ought to pay
the bill
there's a moral component to this too
okay and so roll up your sleeves young
man get your car paid off get your
student loan paid off and go get you
some money and buy a house and prosper
we want you to do that i want you to go
through financial peace university and
we're gonna teach you how to handle
money and i'm gonna pay for it i'm gonna
give it to you for free hold on i like
you austin's gonna pick up and he's
gonna we're gonna help you do all of
this
good stuff speaking of austin there's
another one on the phone fredericksburg
virginia austin is calling hi austin how
are you
i'm going fine how are you doing mr
ramsey better than i deserve what's up
hey yeah so i had a question on active
duty navy um i'm doing
the tsp right now and a lot of people
seem to think that
they should get out of the ces and
iphones and go to g fund to i guess
secure their genes a lot of people
that's what i say
they said not heard is the worst
financial planning firm out there
exactly i had one lady tell me that i
haven't been doing it as long as her so
i don't know what i'm talking about yeah
so i said that's okay you're one day
older two days dumber
wow
that's a good one i like that that's one
way to get slapped
yeah yeah you need to be in there and
thank you for your service yes
absolutely so you know what to put it in
what are you going to put what are you
going to put it in austin
see you again sir what what are you
which plans are you going to put it in
you know what to do right
yes sir what is it
c
c
c s and i exactly 80 10 80 10 10 80
percent of the c 10 and the s and 10 in
the i and just smile at the sweet lady
and
drive on past her she's driving 30
you'll be driving a hundred
exactly
and um thank you man and put it in the
roth version too you got roth available
to you now
absolutely yeah that's that's where it's
been since i've joined yeah you're if
you just do that and you fill that up
and you serve 20 years and you get
military retirement and you have a three
quarters of a million dollars in your c
plan you're going to be millionaire man
you're going to be in great shape
absolutely yep i just ran listed for six
years so we're working on it there you
go man it's awesome again thank you for
your service now there's a a few funds
in here he's mentioned csig everyone
might be going what the heck is this so
the g is the government securities
investment fund which we don't recommend
translation no rates of return horrible
rate of return and then there's the
fixed income index investment which is
the f fund next worst also sucks and the
rest are the csi common stock index
that's the c and that one is tied to the
performance of the s p 500 which is why
we say put the majority of your money
into that it's performed the best of all
the options over the years and then the
s is going to be your stocks from small
to mid-size companies and i is going to
be your international so it's a little
bit and they're diversified yeah in your
portfolio just like we talk about with
your mutual funds
growth growth and income aggressive
growth in international and this is a
pretty close to that mix the reason i go
a little heavier in the sea on this is
out of everything it's outperformed all
the funds substantially inside the tsp
and so substantially but again it's
going to model about after the s p 500
which is going to put you around 11 12
average rate of return
and
over time now i mean right now it's down
it's on sale just like the rest of stock
market
so if you're worried about your
retirement by the way
um
i think i don't think i'm gonna buy
something while it's on sale i think i'm
gonna wait and it goes up oh boy don't
do that timing the market never said no
one ever about shoes
you know i'm going to miss the sale
intentionally and wait till they go up i
go the rachel cruz method if it's on
sale we're buying it
there we go no
you don't know oh no
no
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage brent
and chelsea are with us hey guys how are
you hi good good thank you how are you
better than i deserve where you guys
from
we are from jasper indiana ah good to
have you hey how much debt have you paid
off so we have paid off uh 125 thousand
dollars very good how long did that take
it took us about eight years good and
your range of income during that time so
when we started it was basically right
when we were getting married and both of
us were bringing in a hundred and ten
thousand together okay
and nowadays nowadays we're eighty three
thousand five hundred good very good
what do you all do for a living i am a
group leader uh for a local manufacturer
in jasper jasper engines and
transmissions of course
world famous yes
and i'm a stay-at-home mother wow okay
very good very good so hundred and
twenty-five thousand over eight years is
that your house
a house and a uh a van
people
yes no house payments yes it's been
great wow
what's this house worth so the house um
as far as when we purchase it what's it
worth right now worth right now probably
about 180 000. i love it yeah and you
own it by guys yes we sure i like it
it's exciting
well done so and then uh you know before
we got married um it was one of those as
far as how we got involved with this was
our pastor that we were doing marriage
counseling classes with he recommended
we take a financial peace university did
you yep yes we sure did followed his
recommendation that got the whole thing
started yes it was a rough journey at
first but we stayed on track i played
off my student loans and then we
cashflowed the wedding and then finally
we worked together once we got married
to be able to
um start with our debt free journey
and everything yeah we cashflowed
three kids you'll see them soon
the roof we had a roof we had air
conditioning we had a new veh another
van
just everything open heart surgery wow i
did um yes yes throw that in there yeah
yeah
no big deal right
so
i've been very fortunate but yeah yeah
so i mean you know the principles that
you teach it really taught us you know
early on in our relationship of being
able to work through some of those
struggles that we had uh going going
throughout our marriage here so yeah
yeah
powerful very powerful way to go you two
thank you quite how does it feel to not
have a payment in the world
it's been great you know we uh we paid
off the house at the beginning of march
uh and timing was good you know god is
good he knows when we're supposed to do
this stuff because as soon as we paid
that off we started having things go
broke basically uh you know we had an
issue with our van that was a 1400 bill
we had other issues in the house and it
just seemed things were piling on right
there and it was so nice on having that
mortgage because we were able to use
that money then to go towards that uh
which was really helpful for us how old
are you two i'm 35 33 with a paid for
house i'm seeing a trend here dave these
young people are getting a hold of this
stuff going we don't have to have a
house payment until we retire that's
okay
mortgage does not mean for my whole life
i'm not doing that yes exactly yeah you
guys are incredible so over an eight
year journey you had a lot of stuff
going on yes what kept you going that
long
i have to say there's three people in my
life as our parents definitely both
sides but one in particular uh her name
stacy she always told me it's a marathon
it's not a sprint keep going don't you
can't pay it off tomorrow like just be
patient
last six to eight months was a really
close friend of mine amanda she just
paid her house off at the end of fall
last year so she just kept me going and
said don't give up she had the right
kind of people around you yes an
appliance technician
i know he was a he's a dave ramsey
fan too
and he really pushed and coached me and
stuff too so it was just people were
coming and just helping us
friends of the family and then you know
just some that just so happen to come
into our life you know an appliance
repair guy just coming into the house
and just conversation takes off you know
yes so so really neat yeah
and we have the fourth one coming soon
yeah very very cool very cool what
advice do you have to somebody who's
just getting started
uh don't give up um you know keep on
pushing through and that's coming from
the free spirit of the relationship here
you know uh chelsea i tell everybody we
wouldn't be where we were if it wasn't
for chelsea you know she was the nerd
she's the she she loves dave
uh you know and following what he he
teaches listen in the podcast
she tells me she'll be cleaning the
house listen to the podcast and just
breaking down crying because of the the
debt-free scream story she's hearing
uh you know so just keep on pushing
because it's so worth it at the end
being able to have that uh that relief
of knowing you don't have to pay
those monthly payments
really any longer to the for a loan that
you have yeah you guys have completely
changed your family tree yeah is that
settled in do you get that yeah yeah but
you're good it's so stinking rich yeah
it's fun it's and that's one reason why
i wanted to because i knew i wanted a
bigger family we wanted a bigger family
and
just having that was just nice and it's
peace for me definitely staying at home
i can
have a little bit more comfort with him
only one income so you two are heroes
i'm so proud of you thank you very much
very very very well done thank you we
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that's the next chapter in your
story and for sure you're going to be
one of those and a copy of total money
makeover for you too
and uh the financial peace university
you said you've been through that maybe
you can give it away there's a one year
um
one-year subscription to that and we'll
get that activated for you and you can
either give it away or you can do it
let's get the kiddos in the shot the
three that are the three that are here
yes we got one on the way yeah and what
are their names and ages so we have got
harper over here she is five we've got
millie right here she is three and then
we have ruby she is one ah beautiful
baby number four is due uh september
first beautiful do we know what it is no
we don't find out oh okay we're good
we're we're we're weird we don't i like
that
i've got one daughter that does that i
got the other one that won't tell you
the name
so we always have some kind of a
surprise every time we get one way to go
you guys beautiful beautiful beautiful
well done all right brent and chelsea
harper millie and ruby jasper indiana
125 000 paid off in eight years making
110 to 83. she's home with the babies
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three
two one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
way to go you guys
way to go
i love it i needed some good news today
dave after reading all those headlines
so this is the good news i needed yeah
just in case you think the world's
falling apart dial in about and watch
about six or eight dead free screams in
a row you'll just be crying and you'll
know there's hope you can still win even
in today's economy
you can always win you can win in any
economy because it's not up to them
whether you win it's up to you whether
you win you have to make the decision
if i can control the guy in my mirror he
can be skinny and rich
but he's got issues he likes donuts
i mean you just gotta it's a problem
it's a problem we are in control of more
of our life than anyone else is
the outside variables do not have as
much control over you as your
panic-ridden
uh adrenaline-fed brain from watching
too much cable news has got you freaked
out
and you think that everything's going to
cave in on you it's not
it's not
it has as much power as you give it
you are in control
not a hundred percent but almost
you're in control you can move
you can work in a different job
you're in control you can sell the car
you cannot buy that car
you're in control
you are in control you're not forced
this is a free country you don't have to
choose stupid
you can choose wisdom
it's an option
and these people
like brenton chelsea do it all the time
it's inspiring and they mentioned you
got to surround yourself with positivity
they were watching dead free screams
they had people who told them they could
do it and most of america is surrounded
by
negative headlines negative people
tweets yeah
if all your friends have a eeyore as
their spirit animal
oh it's bad it's always going to be bad
a little man can't get ahead you need
new friends go find you a tigger your
friends are losers
you need new friends
somebody has a smile somebody believes
you can do it somebody tells you you got
a shot somebody tells you go for it
write that song write that book paint
that painting
open that small business
come on guys
throw your shoulders back
act like you care act like you got
something cause you do
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today well one of our friends
dropped by
last time she was here she was uh
promoting her latest book at the time
and has a book coming out later in the
fall but was in town offered to come by
and say hello and anytime we get that
opportunity we take it ambassador or
governor or just nikki nikki haley is
with us
she is famously the first minority
female governor in america when she was
governor of south carolina the first
female first minority governor in south
carolina and the u.s ambassador the
united nations as well uh it's been a
wild
journey and uh i love i hadn't seen this
margaret thatcher quote in forever and
it's one of my faves if you want
something said ask a man if you want
something done ask a woman
i mean right pull that up in front of
your mouth and that became the title of
your new book if you want something done
i love that there we go well i mean it's
true like come on nikki that's a little
sexist it's really not it's it's really
not i look i'm a big fan of women and i
know that we tend to be perfectionists
we balance we're good at what we do and
the truth is
um you know men are great when they want
to do something they jump they don't
think about it women when they do
something they have thought about it
they know exactly what they're doing and
how they're going to do it and they get
it done and you know i think lady
thatcher had it right she did the women
that enter
the space of public service or politics
and do it successfully are
unusually confident and strong people in
general but women as well marsha
blackburn's a good friend yes she's a
great example lady thatcher you
others i think of people like that uh
condoleezza rice yes exactly brilliant
and poised and uh
really just i mean
one of my friends we were with condi and
uh he said i think her purse is smarter
than me
[Laughter]
he's probably right yeah she she's off
the scale smart so yeah so that's going
to be the uh going to be the launcher if
you want something done that's the title
of the new book coming out in the fall
so what are you working on right now
because i know it's not book tour you
must be working on politics you know
we're working on policy and politics i
mean the the politics is easy people
love to talk about the politics but the
truth is it's the policy we need to
worry about i mean as i go across the
country
um campaigning for other people it's the
issues that they care about and you know
more than anybody what they're talking
about is the fact that their wallets are
empty and
you look at the fact that families are
now having to spend six thousand dollars
more a year than they did last year and
what i can tell you dave you do god's
work in the way that you talk to your
audience but if michael and i had to
spend six thousand dollars more a year
when we were raising our kids do you
know where we got that from
a credit card i've heard the rumor and
that's what's happening all over america
and people are scared and they look at
the fact that
they've only got on average 12 000 in
savings they're dipping into that
you've got 30 trillion dollars in debt
the average i mean
the amount of money
each taxpayer owes is 242 000 if you
look at a 30 trillion dollar debt that's
not per household that's per taxpayer it
is irresponsible and unconscionable that
we're in this situation
but it happened from republicans and
democrats right so you've got a 30
trillion dollar in debt
and when all of this happens
the last spending bill
they passed 5 000 earmarks totaling 10
billion dollars with a b republicans and
democrats did that
these were things like 12 million
dollars for a baseball field in new york
15 million dollars to try and get the
world cup to new jersey six and a half
million for golf courses in colorado at
a time where families are struggling
that's just immoral
and that's the part we have to wake
america up on which is when real
families are struggling
at the gas station but they have to go
to work and at the grocery store and
they have to feed their families
we've got to get
people in office that understands the
value of a dollar
governors can do that and you are sat in
the governor's seat in south carolina
they can do that on a state level
maybe because there's
less of a machine maybe because there's
less complexity
but you had to have some insight from
having sat in that seat on that this can
be done or is it just to
go is the machine just too gummed up and
we've just got to send almost all of
them home and start again well i think
it's a couple of things i mean first of
all there shouldn't be anything gummed
up or partisan about balancing a budget
you know i mean households do it small
businesses do it you never spend more
than you have so government should do
the same thing um how does south
carolina run a balanced budget yes and
you know c does by by a constitution
yeah you have to and you should and i
think that being an executive
what i
focused on and what every executive
focuses on is you can't necessarily
focus on partisanship you've got to lift
up everybody and in order to lift up
everybody you just have to do good
common sense approaches so we looked at
our the people that were on welfare and
we said how do we lift them up and so
what we did was we went to our small
businesses and and said look if you will
hire them
for this many weeks we will pay for them
and all we're asking for you to do is
train them well after that time was up
they would hire those people because
they invested the time
and they thought they were and they fell
in love with them and we put thousands
of people from welfare to work just by
connecting the dots that's what has to
be done that's the role government can
do is to put people together so that
people aren't on the government dole
but you know you have to focus on that
now part of that is policy we like to
give the government and white house a
hard time but what are some practical
policy policy decisions that congress
can make to help these american families
who are struggling well i think they
need to balance the budget i need i
think they need to stop this wasteful
spending
all the ear marks that they have started
they need to stop all of that there's
not one american that wants them to be
doing that right now and they've got to
stop and i think they've got to roll
back these regulations that they're
putting on businesses you know what i've
always said is if you can give a person
a job you take care of a family small
businesses try and take care of a lot of
families the best thing government can
do is get out of their way
when businesses have cash flow they
don't run out and go on vacation they
hire people and we've got to make sure
that they can take care of their people
we've got to make sure we get through
this economy and you do that by taking
care of your small businesses you do
that by getting government out of the
way and you do that by lifting people up
and we have an opportunity to get
through this nightmare but we got to be
smart about it and throwing more money
at it is not the answer
that's for sure so you're going to run
for president
you know i don't have to make a decision
until january i mean i have said i
have never lost a race i'm not going to
start now if there's a place for me i'll
put a thousand percent into it and i'll
finish it if there's not a place for me
i love this country and i'll fight for
her until my last breath well i didn't
expect you to announce it here but i
just thought i'd ask that would have
been awesome though
although you know i'm such a fan of
yours that would be kind of fun
that would probably not be your wisest
political move i'm just saying but yeah
that's fun well we appreciate that very
very much thank you so much for coming
by all right if you want something done
is the new book coming out in the fall
so what's what's in the book
you know you can pre-order it today um
go to nikkiehaley.com but basically the
book is the publisher asked me if i
would write this because there were
books about
many leaders but there wasn't a book
about female leaders and so what we
focused on is female leaders from all
walks of life
um all
domestic and international and it talks
about their struggle their story and
their courage
and you know i go and i also with every
profile i talk about a story of mine
that relates to that and i think what i
try and tell people men and women is we
all have war stories and war stories are
those times where you were most
uncomfortable those times it pushed you
in a way that you didn't think you'd
make it and those times that you
overcame and what happens is you learn
an amazing lesson when you do that and
so i always tell people push through the
fear get those war stories because when
you have war stories that's when you're
living life if you don't have war
stories you never know what could have
been these women that are profiled in
this book they all had amazing war
stories they were normal people that
became extraordinary so maggie
thatcher's in there she is absolutely in
there prominently michael reagan is a
good friend of mine and he's he says
that uh his that ronald reagan would not
have been what the ronald reagan that we
know if maggie hadn't been across the
pond at the same time and i don't know
that she would have been the leader she
was if ronaldo without without ronald
yeah that was an amazing question some
very interesting teamwork and friendship
there absolutely nikki haley thank you
for stopping by we want to hear from you
we want to know what your plans are okay
it's always fun to be here thank you
love it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day
proverbs 26 20 without wood a fire goes
out and without gossip a quarrel dies
down
who knew proverbs got there first
they knew about gossip
norman vince appeal said nothing is more
confusing than people who give good
advice but set a bad example
hypocrisy
there's that that'll get you
good stuff so uh kelly said at the break
she said what if what if uh ambassador
nikki haley had announced her
presidential race on the ramsey show we
would have all passed out that's what we
would have done at the table had
absolutely no illusions that that was
going to happen
the only thing that could make it better
is if dave announced he was running as
uh vp
with her that would no she would have
had been my vp george oh
okay
i believe that
she we were talking in the break have
you ever known me to have a boss
that's true
and that's why dave will not be part of
the government anytime
soon that's exactly right i guarantee
you i don't need to pay cut
she's so poised it's awesome just i mean
we were talking about it she's just
there's a different thing happening with
people like that with condoleezza rice
we're talking about her just the level
of intellect um it's incredible yeah
well and
yeah i don't know
these people that play on the national
political stage at a at a big level i
mean they have a charisma
and it's um i've never met uh president
bill clinton but everyone that i know
that has ever met him says he's the most
endearing
that in person that he's just um
everybody likes him
even his enemies i mean even people who
completely disagree with him politically
or morally or whatever hang out with the
guy i just love it and i've heard that
from
lots and lots of people i mean
again i've never met him but i've heard
that and i've heard the opposite about
others but um
yeah
there's something about those folks it's
a different it's a different thing so
yeah we poke fun at them all the time
and uh the politicians and the
the presidents and all those kinds of
things but they are some good apples out
there too there's some there's some good
ones in the bunch
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life and your money
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host daniel is with us daniel is in
san antonio texas hey daniel how are you
i'm doing good sir how about so better
than i deserve how can i help
uh yes sir me and my wife are facing
kind of a
dilemma right now um
so her father passed away at the
beginning of the year due to a heart
attack
um she's
she's received a settlement
um
and we just we're having trouble trying
to figure out how to deal with it
um
we're facing scrutiny from her sister
who believes she's entitled to it um he
had several life insurances
so each of the children got one
and she just so happened to get the
biggest uh portion
and she was the only beneficiary on it
so
her dad had multiple life insurance
policies and he wrote down the
beneficiary on each one and each kid got
different amounts of insurance but that
was all his decision
yes sir and your wife received how much
roughly
500 000. and her sister received how
much
um one received i believe a hundred
thousand
and the other received about sixteen
thousand
the one that got fifteen is the one
that's pissed
yes okay so why do you think her dad did
that
um we
so we were in the military um
for the last couple years of his life
and he traveled everywhere around the
world to see us
we developed a great long-distance
relationship with him
and
as far as our personal achievements we
we've been the first to get a house on
our own do everything as far as
adult-wise on our own
so
your your wife's sister feels like she's
entitled to something that her dad did
not want her to have
thank you yes sir
why does she feel like she's entitled to
something her dad didn't want her to
have because if he'd wanted her to have
it he would have put her name on the
policy
and i've i've said that as well sir um
at the same time i'm not we're not money
motivated um that doesn't matter it's
yes sir the money doesn't matter
the arrogance of your
sister-in-law is appalling
i mean
if the old man wanted her to have the
money he would put her name on the thing
yes sir
so why does she think she's entitled
what is she saying
what does she say um
just constantly checking up to see if
the money has been received
no no that wasn't what i asked i asked
why she thinks you're supposed to give
her money
i have no excuse she hasn't said you owe
me this because
no sir she just said you owe me this
um
[Music]
not not those exact words but
um as far as checking up see if we got
the money uh uh well that's none of our
business plans for the money
well that's none of our business
yes sir
and if she didn't also well i mean she
has she ever come out and said she wants
it
uh yes so the original plan was to split
it amongst three and i was discussed by
them
who pride the sisters all three sisters
but that was prior and that was prior to
finding out the information that he had
multiple life insurance
so he never told them the situation he
never laid it out and said hey there's
different policies here's how much is in
each
that's part of this is it was a big
surprise at the end
oh yes sir it's not a final just always
told them if in
okay at one point did your sis did your
wife and her sisters get together and
decide they're gonna split this before
he died or after he died
ask her
i'm so confused why they would do that
but they didn't know that there was
multiple policies in the amounts at that
point
what was it they were agreeing to split
then
um from their understanding like i said
there was only
an understanding of one life insurance
so they had planned to
take the state to the probate court
split their state evenly it's not it's
not it doesn't go to probate court
life insurance proceeds come straight to
you
unless they're named unless the
beneficiary is an estate
which would be the dumbest thing you
could possibly do with a life insurance
policy
no sarah was and it wasn't my wife's
name it does not go to probate court it
just goes to your wife it's her money
period
i'm not you have any indication that the
old man intended for this money to be
split
um no sir
none
then why did the girls decide to split
it
because they thought that was the only
thing that he had left as far as money
was
yeah but but then what if he didn't want
him to split it
yes sir um after the realization that he
had multiple life insurances
um
they
[Music]
they ceased uh their communication about
the life insurance oh
then it became a mystery
and my wife me and my wife were trying
to figure out what to do with it i told
her it was up to her whatever she
decided here's the thing here's the
thing you cannot give them money if the
reason you're giving them money is
because you think that saves the
relationship
because a relationship that is purchased
is prostitution it's not relationship
that makes completion
okay and so if you're if you're thinking
oh the only way my sister's ever going
to speak to me again is if i split money
with her then she ain't worth having
if the only reason she speaks to me is
if i give her money i don't need her
that's no longer that's no longer
somebody you have to impress if their
relationship severed because of this
it's not on your wife yeah it's not on
you guys and you don't do it to save the
relationship
and you don't do it but to prove that
you're not money motivated you would
only really would split all this up is
if you felt like it was morally the
right thing to do and you felt like the
old man meant to do that and he just
never got around to doing the paperwork
right
yeah
you wanted to honor him
he wanted to honor his wishes but it
sounds to me like his wishes have been
verified they're called a beneficiary on
a life insurance policy
i uh sister-in-law can take it up with
dad in the next life but this is not
she doesn't need to go be going after
your wife for this i'm sorry hunt him
down in heaven
[Laughter]
get over it yeah no i wouldn't give her
the money
i wouldn't i i don't think or any reason
here for you to do that it has nothing
to do with you being greedy because
you're not
that's not the point
you people when you're doing your estate
plans tell all the people what's
happening for you die don't leave your
kids in this situation if they won't be
pissed at you you need to do it while
you're alive have some guts that puts us
out of the ramsey show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ
jesus do you love a good dave rant want
to see the latest ramsay show videos
going viral check out your favorite
moments from the ramsay show on youtube
go watch and subscribe to the ramsay
show channel on youtube
[Music]
you